can that six percent
unemployment number
uh says this
if you run a company or a city
or a state that is not
operating right now because of the
pandemic
you are 94 percent wrong
that's exactly right it's good math yes
because the fact of the matter is that
is taking in the entire country where
you've got some states that are on
virtual lockdown yeah 33 million people
are in lockdown in los angeles alone
yeah
and so uh you know
the if you're if you are purporting to
be a leader in government and you're not
open
by definition mathematically you are now
94 wrong well dave there's a spike in
our area
i yeah and
94 of americans are now working
and their businesses are running
and so uh you know if you aren't open
or allowing people in your area to open
you are
by definition mathematically wrong
yeah let's look at where we were
february before the pandemic before we
even realize it's a pandemic we were at
3.4 percent
unemployment which was a historically
low unemployment number
and we also had a very sound
fundamentals we had sound fundamentals
in the economy so now what you're seeing
despite all the shutdowns we've had
rolling shutdowns open up now they're
back down again
and we're also looking at let's just
look at the way the american economy
runs here
we are a consumer economy we essentially
pass each other's money around
in that we're so driven by the service
industries and the service industries
are still getting hammered
and a lot of those people are not
working hourly wage earners
uh people making the 4000.
that's about the only ones left that are
still hurt by this that's right are
entry-level people and people in the
hospitality world that's right
restaurants hotels that's right god help
you if you're in the cruise line yeah
uh those kinds of things where where
everyone else
is back moving in spite of
government misbehavior that's correct in
spite of
and there's still and some restaurants
are doing just fine and others aren't
yes
yes and it has to do with the local
political climate
and uh and and the the
you know public giving each other the
side eye in the name of uh political
correctness is what this has become
it really has become political that's
right uh it used to be medical
but it has evolved into this so that
that's very interesting to think about
that oh you know we lost we had a 40
percent
wasn't it unemployment night we got into
the we got we had the spike in april
may we're in that close to 30 percent 31
33
unemployment rate the highest ever and
since we've been keeping records except
a great deal without doubt and then
immediately
and immediately back to about 12 percent
nobody's talking about it nobody all
they're talking about is stay inside
right but let's just let's just imagine
that if we if we
get back to restaurants and vacations
and people flying
uh you're going to see that number from
6.3 percent you're going to see it
get really really low again so prefer
there were no people flying i prefer
they were in an airplane when they were
flying
well said you got me on the technicality
that's a good point
people can't fly yeah i'm not aware of
any new technology folks i didn't mean
to break anything there uh
erroneously on the dave ramsey show but
here's the point that we're making
i don't want you to not make a decision
like this young man and i understand
this is my point don't make a decision
on what you think might happen
as it might shut down again when i think
in all reality
uh let's see when the vaccine let's see
what happens when the vaccine gets
widely distributed i'm not going to get
into
what do you want to take it or not but
when consumer confidence and politicians
confidence
meet up together you're going to see a
big roar in this economy this american
economy is going to roar
because people want to go somewhere and
do things and eat outside or eat inside
for heaven's sakes
so when that happens uh i think you're
gonna see uh production
up big time manufacturing up uh you know
the trade economy
is going to refresh and a friend was
asking me so where are all these
breadlines these people in line for food
coming from us well
why is why don't we not have that in
2008 because 2008 was more protracted
and lengthened than this was that's
right and why is that well it's because
of who this hit
this hit the service industry people
cleaning the rooms in the hotels
people waiting the tables yes people uh
that's a fact
in may we saw a number dave 40 in the
month of may that at that point
40 percent of people who made 40 000 or
less had lost their
is jobs this economic shutdown
hit the lower socioeconomic rungs on the
latter
the hardest it's like this young man
he's just getting started
so he's on that rung right i've been on
that run and the point of a ladder is to
climb the ladder so that
it's not insulting to anybody okay but
if you are
entry level you're the one's gotten
hammered
factory jobs where they just declared
that the
company was uh scared out of their bones
and publicly traded pansies and wouldn't
you know that wouldn't stay open
wouldn't keep running
and uh and they caused the loss of the
jobs
of thousands of thousands of people that
needed the jobs the most
food for thought for leaders out there
decision makers politicians
another of the hardest hit demographics
in the american workforce is the working
mother
women who want to be moms but also
pursue their professional career and
they've had to come home
because the school's being closed and
it's really hurting women in the
workplace
just just just let you know it's it's
really hitting people that you don't
expect to hit
so maybe the teachers should go back to
work but there's a thought
oh my god i don't know i'm just old
i just you know work solves a lot of
stuff for people
because it's a surefire money-making
scheme